with sonic the hedgehog 2 hitting
theaters kids are sure to enjoy the
speedy antics of everyone's favorite
blue hedgehog but what about the
grown-ups is there anything in the film
for them keep watching to see the things
only adults notice and sonic the
hedgehog 2.
the opening of sonic the hedgehog 2
picks up a handful of months after the
first movie ends dr robotnik has largely
adapted to his new reality exiled on the
mushroom planet to keep himself company
as a castaway in this strange land
robotnik has made a friend for himself
that is reminiscent of wilson from the
2000 tom hanks movie castaway in that
film a lonely fedex delivery man played
by hanks spoke to a volleyball he
nicknamed wilson even going so far as to
paint a face on it the roberts of
mecca's film was a huge hit not only at
the box office but also earns the actor
an oscar nomination and a golden globe
award
from bart simpson to timmy turner
sometimes the best way to stick the
landing on an energetic pre-teen boy is
by using a grown-up woman to provide his
voice that's the case with sonic
sidekick tales as the two-tailed fox has
brought to life by veteran voice actress
colleen o'shaughnessy the industry vet
who began her career in the early 90s
via series like sailor moon and digimon
does a convincing job of bringing the
endearing character to life that won't
be surprising to older fans who have
been following the sonic video games for
years though shawnee has been voicing
tales in various games and shows for
almost a decade now as o'shaughnessy
began voicing tales in sonic games in
2014 with her first appearances as a fox
coming in sonic boom shattered crystal
for the nintendo ds handheld video game
system and sonic boom rise of lyric both
released in november 2014. she has since
voiced tales in over a dozen other sonic
games as well as the 85 episode long
sonic boom tv series
don't worry it's still covered by the
manufacturer's warranty when we first
see robotnik's lucky agent stone in
sonic the hedgehog 2 he is cranking out
cappuccinos at a coffee shop named the
mean bean cafe this name is a reference
to an old sonic the hedgehog spin-off
game called dr robotnik's mean bean
machine mean bean machine was first
released on the sega genesis in 1993. it
was a brightly coloured falling block
puzzle game where you must match up
beans in groups to clear the board and
there was an almost direct translation
to english from the japanese game puyo
puyo replacing the original designs with
sonic characters
not every adult targeted sonic 2 joke
refers to an old video game or movie
kids might find themselves wondering why
agent stone is so fiercely loyal to an
office rocker madman who frequently puts
him in painful situations adults on the
other hand might see a romance blooming
the robotnik stone relationship has tons
of suggestive subtext particularly at
the beginning of the film the two have
been separated for some time and stone
is methodically fashioning images of the
duo into latte foam complete with cute
hearts he seems to be the smithers to
robotnik's mr burns and much like
smithers he'll endure any humiliation if
it means he can remain in the orbit of
his apparent crush the suggestion that
stone is into robotnik as more than just
a boss is shown in multiple scenes like
one where we see him playing virtual
dress-up with robotnik on his computer
stone's desire to see his boss happy
despite the way robotnik treats him as
disposable reinforces that this desire
is more than simply professional
early in the movie tom is concerned
about sonic's well-being after settling
into green hills following the events of
the first sonic the hedgehog movie the
blue speed demon has been having trouble
finding his calling a wannabe superhero
the hedgehog goes around bungling crimes
in progress sometimes saving the day but
often in the most expensive ineffective
ways possible in an attempt to be the
hero he thinks everyone needs him to be
sonic finds himself rudderless tom tells
sonic that his time will come and that
fate will tell him he doesn't need to
force that moment to happen that moment
chooses you i just got goosebumps wait a
second did you steal that from oprah
this goes on to be one of the relevant
themes of the movie and what motivates
its main character tom is concerned that
sonic needs to find friends and peers
that are more like him which ends up
happening when tails and knuckles enter
the story it's only near the end of the
movie that we see this journey completed
though sonic tails and knuckles have
formed bonds and matured together for a
greater purpose and as the film teases a
new threat for sonic the hedgehog 3 they
stand united to battle him
in the first film audiences learn that
sonic was raised by a clan of great owls
from a faraway dimension in sonic the
hedgehog 2 it's revealed that the owls
in particular sonic's maternal figure
longclaw are the rivals of the echidna
clan that knuckles was born into making
sonic and knuckles sworn enemies by
birth in reality both of these animals
exist here on earth while hedgehogs and
echidnas may look similar to the
untrained eye they are quite different
creatures an echidna has a thinner
longer muzzle and sharper quills and
hedgehogs have smaller feet while
echidnas grow longer toenails named for
a greek mythological half monster
echidnas can be found in new guinea and
mainland australia along with tasmania
and as far as we know they are not
engaged in conflict in some wild space
dimension
the main plot for dr robotnik and sonic
the hedgehog 2 centers around a team up
between the mad scientist and knuckles
the echidna has a lifelong rivalry
against the owl clan that race sonic and
therefore has a grudge against the blue
speedster the same sense of duty that
leads knuckles to despise sonic without
even getting to know him drives a red
spike ball to seek the master emerald
the source of power robotnik seeks for
his evil schemes robotnik offers
knuckles a deal that appears simple on
the surface but adult audiences will
likely predict the inevitable betrayal
to come throughout the movie robotnik
gives many indicators that he is not to
be trusted all of them apparently flying
over the head of knuckles too blinded by
vengeance to pick up on his shady
collaborator ultimately this gives
knuckles an edge making him a formidable
foe for sonic and then eventually a
powerful friend at the end of sonic 2
knuckles and sonic look like they are
destined to become quite the team
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]